je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
l'année dernière je vous avait emmené
avec moi un lisbonne pourrait découvrir
la dernière action can2go projeter la
gopro heroes 8 black et j'étais très fan
de cette caméra
d'ailleurs je suis toujours très très
fan c'est un excellent modèle sx comme
un homme de paix venait à peine au bled
et nourriture et ppa quesnel les mains
et la gopro vient de lancer un tout
nouveau modèle mais un tout nouveau
modèle c'est celle là c'est la neuve nac
du cac
mais avant toute chose et si c'est pas
déjà fait vous invite à venir vous
abonnez vous avez un petit bouton rouge
qui hélas il est rouge si vous voulez
toujours pas abonné cliquez dessus comme
ça vous soit là tout sur la tutelle
qu'on parle bien évidemment de caméra
gopro on parle beaucoup de smartphones
de brodeuses tablettes ordinateurs est
en passe autour de vous et de votre vie
numérique savoir quels sont les bons
usages qu'est ce qu'il faut faire ou ne
pas faire
qu'est ce qui est bien qu est-ce qu il
ait pas de cliquer sur le petit bouton
rouge ici actionner la cloche comme ça
vous serez notifié dès qu une prochaine
vidéo arrive et ça c'est très cool à
chaque nouvelle version ou gopro nous
régale on a vraiment une belle
progression entre l'ancien modèle et
nouveaux modèles et surtout de nouvelles
fonctionnalités qui arrive l'année
dernière je te dis déjà avec la limite
blacks ils ont fait extrêmement fort je
vois pas trop où ils peuvent aller et
qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent encore nous
proposer mieux il y avait quelques
petits points d'amélioration mais très
très léger c'était déjà vraiment
excellents termes de stabilisation aux
termes d'image on avait un rendu qui
était vraiment exceptionnel
et là il nous régale encore plus avec
7,9 blacks en terme d'image au terme de
stabilisation en termes de photos il ya
beaucoup de points d'amélioration et
c'est vraiment un excellent produit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regardez-moi ça comme ses couleurs c'est
la boîte normalement il ya la gopro de
l'armée doit bien évidemment déjà enlevé
à l'intérieur de la boîte normalement
j'ai ici ma go pro qui est planqué juste
ici j'ai un petit stick alors ça c'est
peut-être que dans un pack médias je
sais pas si vous vous l'aurez à
confirmer j'ai une deuxième petite
batterie différents types d'attache mais
surtout ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est ça ça c'est la 8
blacks là on a l'a 9 blacks on a déjà
une différence de forme à la noble acte
est un peu plus grosse que les huit
black dont je vous ai bien vous en
rendre compte comme ça elle est
également un poil plus lourde ce qui est
toujours conservé ce qui est génial sur
le stand accroche que vous avez en bas
qui arrivait avec l'a8 black et ça c'est
vraiment extraordinaire parce que vous
mettez directement sur vos supports vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous embêter
donc ça c'est vraiment vraiment bien
parce qu'avant on se casser un peu les
lois et c'était pas terrible avec toute
la coque que vous aviez au tour donc ça
c'est vraiment très très bien et c'est
une superbe idée bravo go pro et surtout
et vous le voyez là ici on a un écran
lcd et ça ça change vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de choses
l'écran que vous avez à la vente un
écran le 1.4 pouces tandis qu'à
l'arrière vous avez un écran qui est
quand même 16% plus large que ce que
vous aviez avant avec votre tweet black
avec cet écran lcd je peux venir tout
voir il n'est pas tactile donc je peux
strictement rien de piloter ici si je
veux piloter je viens derrière j'ai mes
photos ma vidéo mon accélérée c'est
exactement le même principe
si vous voulez voir déjà ce que vous
faites c'est bien si vous interviewez
quelques années personne ne pourra se
voir en face si vous voulez l'utiliser
en mode blog et bien vous verrez donc ça
c'est aussi super bien et pour faire des
scènes fils est aussi super bien donc ça
c'est vraiment génial
la nôtre points qui étaient aussi
améliorer c'est le fait qu'on ait
bientôt qu'ils sont quand même un peu
plus grand alors c'est pas forcément
flagrant comme ça mais le bouton like
vous assurez un peu plus grand que celui
là et c'est la même chose pour le bouton
pour l'allumer pour éteindre que vous
avez ici qui est un peu plus grand que
celui là il ya un point qui est
améliorée qui est vraiment important ça
on le retrouve et c'est un défaut sur
l'a8 blacks c'est que ça ça sent le vécu
et c'était pas terrible parce que si
vous le tombé dans la neige ou je ne
sais où et bien des fois c'est pas
génial
là par contre le défaut a été corrigé ça
ne peut plus partir par contre ça pourra
faire râler certaines personnes qui
avaient la gopro 8 black dernière et qui
ont acheté la nouvelle est bien les
batteries ne sont plus du tout
compatible vous ne pouvez pas mettre la
batterie de votre nouvelle 9 blacks dans
votre feedback et vice versa voyez ça ne
marchera pas c'est comme si vous soucier
du 36 et la duke a renvoyé un moment ça
ne fonctionne pas ce qui veut dire que
toutes les batteries antérieurs ne sont
pas compatibles
votre noble ac
[Musique]
on a un tout nouveau capteur de 23,6
millions de pixels ce qui vous permettra
de monter en vidéo jusqu'en cinq cas à
30 images par seconde
vous avez également de la 4k à 60 images
par seconde et surtout vous allez
pouvoir faire des photos jusqu'en bas
mégapixels le rendu des photos est
vraiment beaucoup plus qualitatif que ce
qu'on avait avant et 9 6 août une vidéo
en cinq cartes pouvait extraire des
photos de 14,7 millions de pixels le
gros point fort de go pro c'est la
stabilisation et là on a une meilleure
stabilisation avec l'hyper smooth 3.0
déjà ce qu'on avait les dernières avec
l'a8 bellac c'était énorme
là ils vont encore plus loin et c'est
extrêmement bref toujours de la même
manière chez go projet pouvoir venir
choisir dans vos différents modes en
créer ce que vous voulez vous avez le
mode cinéma qui l'a par défaut le super
view compagnie et vous pouvez filmer je
vous dis jusqu'en cinq cas à 30 images
par seconde et également avec le
maintien de l'horizon ce qu'ils
appelleront l'horizon levine ça me
permet d'avoir toujours le même niveau
d'horizon quel que soit le mouvement de
votre groupe rond et le résultat est
vraiment très bluffant
un autre point qui est aussi vachement
intéressant c'est que vous avez l'option
boost dispo dans tous les réglages
on a donc une image qui est complètement
stabilisé et si vous regardez sur la
vidéo ce qui est assez incroyable
j'avais un petit 4 4 pour le mettre dans
les chemins et tout tester l'image est
tellement stabiliser convoi le 4 4 qui
lève alors ce qui est assez incroyable
en fait c'est que dites vous bien que
lorsqu'on voit le 4 4 qui lève et bien
la caméra levée en même temps et à
l'image le rendu
c'est uniquement le 4 4 qui lève et on
sera pas du tout content que la caméra
est en train de se lever en même temps
[Musique]
domota hvar vous avez la demie vitesse
qui est disponible ici
soit en vitesse réelle soit en militait
c est une nouveauté c'est que lorsque
vous êtes en vitesse réelle
eh bien ça va venir enregistrer l'audio
[Musique]
autre nouveauté l'objectif est
complètement amovible pour pouvoir venir
l'enlever et remplacé par un objectif
max et vous avez un verre corning
gorilla glass qui va venir le protéger
notamment contre les rayures et en cas
de choc bien évidemment parce que si
c'est une groupe pro qu'il ya un nouveau
mode qui fait son arrivée et c'est le
mode webcam si vous souhaitez utiliser
votre gopro comme une webcam notamment
dans le cadre du télétravail et bien
vous pouvez vous allez juste la
connecter avec un câble en usb c'est
vous télécharger l'application pour
votre ordinateur sur le site de go pro
et vous allez pouvoir utiliser et votre
gopro 9 blague en webcam avec un champ
de vision de 130 degrés par contre vous
pouvez toujours le même système pour
venir mais votre carte ici up carte
micro sd vous appuyez-vous la levée
c'est pratique c'est toujours la même
chose qu'on avait avant donc ça ça
fonctionne toujours très très bien pour
nous également ici une meilleure
autonomie avec une plus grosse batterie
de 1720 millan perreur qui vous donnera
30% de plus d'autonomie que l'outback et
surtout cette batterie va supporter des
températures beaucoup plus basse que ce
que vous aviez avec l'a8 bergues
si vous voulez l'emmener pour les
expéditions en sibérie où je ne sais
zouk et bien vous pouvez la prendre sans
aucun problème il ya ne pointe qu
intéressant c'est la capture programmée
elle est justifiée alors là j'ai
désactivé pouvait venir programmer votre
capture vous choisissez vous dites je
veux qu'elles partent demain à telle
heure par exemple si vous voulez faire
un time lapse à à 5 heures du matin pour
le lever du soleil et bien venir le
programme et vous avez pas besoin d'être
sur place vous la poser et elle partira
toute seule comme une grande
à l'heure prévue il ya un autre point
qui est intéressant c'est la insight ça
vous permettra d'enregistrer 15 secondes
ou même trente secondes avant d'avoir
appuyé sur le bouton c'est à dire avant
d'avoir déclenché votre vidéo en gros ce
que ça va faire ici et là c'est que ça
va venir enregistrer en permanence
et lorsque vous allez à cuillé et bien
ça reviendra vous reprendre les 30
secondes avant ou alors les 15 secondes
avant en fonction que vous avez souhaité
ce qui fait que si vous faites un truc
assez extraordinaire et que vous y
arrivez pas comment vous y arrivez tac
vous appuyez et vous n'avez absolument
rien louper ça c'est cool 7 go pro est
livré dans un boîtier réutilisables sans
aucun plastique donc ça c'est bon pour
la planète et vous avez toujours les
modules max qui sont disponibles puis
changez votre objectif pour me remettre
une lumière pouvait rajouter un micro et
même un petit écran lcd on
l'écran lcd aujourd'hui c'est moins
intéressant puisque vous avez l'écran
sur le vendée si vous voulez vous pouvez
vous avez également une nouveauté c'est
la durée de l'enregistrement vous pouvez
mettre sans limite d'enregistrement ou
alors vous pouvez monter crescendo une
minute cinq minutes 15 minutes et vous
montez en tout jusqu'à 3 heures en
fonction de vos besoins ça peut être
bien par exemple si vous allez planifier
un début d'enregistrement je sais pas à
5 heures du matin et que vous voulez
qu'ils enregistrent pendant une heure et
bien vous pouvez le faire sans venir usé
tout votre carte mémoire ou utiliser
toute votre batterie
[Musique]
bah
on va toujours retrouver la commande
vocale vous pouvez la mettre sous l'eau
jusqu'à 10 mètres faire de la diffusion
en direct en 1080p le like birds la
super photo
le hdr vous êtes toujours accès à vos
réglages pro tune moi j'ai mis un débit
élevé je veux mettre un iso max à 400 en
pleine journée ça m'ira très bien une
netteté élevé couleurs gopro audureau
oui non vent automatique mais on va
retrouver également ici une application
pour venir contrôler votre gopro de la
même manière vous appuyer là vous allez
venir vous connecter à votre goût pro
très très facilement vous pouvez activer
l'aperçu en vous connectant directement
au réseau wifi créé par votre gopro peut
venir faire une photo je peux venir
filmer je peux venir fermée ralentis et
je peux même partir en live pour partir
en live il faut que je vienne le
configurer ce qui n'est pas le cas ici
facebook youtube twitter j'ai pas mal de
possibilités bon vous venez rentrée
après une fois de plus vos identifiants
et tout et ça marchera peut être diffusé
en direct grâce à votre groupe
prononcera c'est très très cool vous
avez accès bien évidemment à tous vos
fichiers qui sont à l'intérieur de votre
groupe pro vous pouvez venir récupérer
télécharger et ensuite créer des films
faire du montage exportant vous et quand
même beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de possibilités application disponible
sur ios mais également sur android et
c'est une caméra que vous pouvez trouver
au tarif de 479 euros 99 et vous avez un
pack avec une souscription à go pro plus
qui fait que si vous avez des premiers
peuples gopro vous la chance aucun
problème est extrêmement rapidement et
il ya une promo à 379 euros 98 autant
vous dire que ça vaut le coup d'ailleurs
c'est aux intérêts ce sont un lien en
bas dans la description l'a8 blake a
baissé et coûte aujourd'hui 3 179 99 et
elle reste toujours une excellente
caméra certes il ya des différences mais
si vous voulez une excellente groupe pro
et que un peu moins de 500 euros c'est
pas forcément fait pour vous en dehors
de tout propos ou bien évidemment du
moment et bien là huit banques restent
vraiment d'actualité
vous pouvez retrouvez également la scène
black à 279 euros 99 et j'ai aussi les
tarifs pour les modes alors je vous dis
que je n'ai pas appris par coeur
l'objectif vous trouvez à 99 euros 99 le
média mode 89 euros 99 l'écran 79 euros
99 et l'éclairage à 49 euros 99
moi personnellement je suis extrêmement
fans je pense que gopro continue
d'avancer tous les ans ça c'est clair on
s'en douterait est évidemment mais c'est
très bon et je vous le disais en début
de vidéo
quand j'étais arrivé déjà avec l'a8
black l'année dernière j'ai testé
beaucoup dormi un peu partout avec moi
mais je trouvais qu'on était déjà arrivé
de ne pas dire très loin mais peut-être
le plus loin que ce que je pouvais en
tout cas attendre compte et nous
surprendre et si alors il rajouté
évidemment tout petit écran lcd pour
pouvoir boire au niveau des selphy et
pour pouvoir se filmer en mode bullock
ça c'est extrêmement intéressant d'aller
toujours plus loin au niveau de la
stabilisation ça pour moi c'est vraiment
bluffant le fait d'avoir l'horizon
levine qui est intégré directement dans
votre caméra pareil ça me blesse
énormément et ça marche très très bien
c'est vraiment une superbe caméra
d'action c'est je pense aujourd'hui en
tout cas la meilleure caméra d'actions
qu'elles soient disponibles sur le
marché pour moi je trouve vraiment cool
si vous n'avez jamais eu de go pro si
vous avez le budget à un peu moins de
500 euros dans une excellente caméra
devait pouvoir garder quelques bonnes
années sans aucun problème est bien
celle là est vraiment cool pensez
vraiment aussi à regarder une fois de
plus les accessoires qui vont bien pour
l'adapter sur votre vélo pour mettre sur
un casque pour mettre à votre poitrine
pour le tenir à la main
faut vraiment réfléchir à tout ça pour
voir quelles sont vos usages avec votre
caméra mais la caméra en elle même elle
est vraiment bien et si vous voulez
aujourd'hui la meilleure caméra
d'actions disponibles en marché et bien
vous pouvez sur celle là sans aucun
problème à vous de dire vous maintenant
ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire personnellement je la trouve
très cool et je continue à l'utiliser
pour mes vidéos il à faire des films
avec voilà donc sur ce je vous embrasse
j'en vois beaucoup d'amour et puis ça
vous intéresse venez évidemment n'oublie
pas besoin le lien en bas dans la
description a très tôt
[Musique]